the biden administration is putting its
immigration strategy
in place along with the new homeland
security secretary
alejandro mayorkas the first immigrant
to hold that cabinet post
was sworn in yesterday he took over as
president biden signed a second round of
executive orders
intending to reverse more of the trump
administration's immigration policies
weiji zhang is at the white house wiesha
what do these orders actually do
good morning anthony these orders
certainly send a strong message that
president biden views immigration
differently than former president trump
but we heard from several advocates who
say even though the orders are promising
they lack power to make any swift
substantial
i'm not making new law i'm eliminating
bad policy
president biden signed three orders to
start
undoing his predecessor's immigration
policies
like separating families at the southern
border
the president has created a new task
force to begin
reuniting more than 600 children with
their parents
we're going to work to undo the moral
and national shame
of the previous administration but john
sandweg who served as the acting
director of ice under former president
obama
said it won't be easy because of the
trump administration's
mismanagement it failed to even kind of
put in place basic tracking systems
and so it's an incredibly complex
undertaking the other orders will review
the requirement for
thousands of asylum seekers to stay in
mexico as their cases are
processed and look at restrictions on
legal immigration
the aclu called it troubling that the
orders did not include
immediate action to rescind and unwind
more trump-era policies some republicans
like arizona congressman
andy biggs are blasting mr biden's moves
calling them an open invitation to enter
the country
illegally he's basically reinstating the
catch and release program
with regard to the asylum program
but the white house said their message
to migrants is
not to rush here this is not the time to
come to the united states we need
the time to put in place an immigration
process
so people can be treated humanely the
first lady's office tells cbs news that
she won't have an official role in that
task force to reunite families but dr
jill biden does intend to use her
platform to highlight its work
she has a long history of working with
migrants at the border especially
children tony it's still hard to imagine
that separation happened and with no
tracking
in place to reunite those families in
the first place wija thank you very much